i think it's really beneficial to
explain that process because i feel like
a lot of people want to get in touch
they want to know who they are they want
to grow but they don't really know what
will happen when you start to do that
did you
or
were you were you ready for that did you
know like hey you know everything's
gonna get flipped on its head and my new
life is gonna cost me my old one or was
this sort of the first time in your life
that you've really like stepped into
this unknown territory of
um
change like deep change on a physical
level in a man and a reality level
yeah i think i've made a lifestyle out
of it honestly
i've been doing it for so long i i don't
remember life before it really but um
you know i owe a lot to
you know my my first marriage was we
were together 20 years got married
pretty young had two amazing kids and
was that all
birthed in an environment of
an easy description of success
i went to church i my dad was the pastor
and
i had
you know i met this woman and her dad
was a pastor and both admissions work
and we both wanted kids and
then i decided i was going to be a
doctor and that sounds really nice too
and then i went and became a doctor and
i mean
it's so easy to be like win win win win
or just winning the freaking game here
and that's what i told myself
throughout my 20s throughout
probably the first half of my 30s
and yet there was this emptiness of life
that i could not calculate it was like
nothing seemed to be landing i
felt
uh intense loneliness in my life during
that time and
despite the fact of being surrounded by
thousands of patients and
yeah great kids and
family and amazing immediate family
parents my
three siblings like yeah i
i looked great on paper i looked so good
on paper why was it not freaking
clicking like what what is
what is the essence of this that is
driving me bonkers and so
you know
my
in that 20-year relationship we started
to give each other permission to
challenge the world views that we had
grown up in and
that uncovered deep
traumas you know in oh man
when you hold safe space for growth it
immediately uncovers
the emotional traumas that shapes the
reality that you have been living
and
when you find those you realize
that your life is a reactive state of
trauma management rather than living
there's a big difference between those
two things and one is a slow death and
one is a constant rebirth
and i was really craving a constant
sense of rebirth and renewal in my life
and i was living
a reality of decay and
death within myself in the context of
a world that had handed us a bunch of
social norms and metrics that allow for
us to define
death as success
why do you think some people are more
like that the one you're talking i
relate to you totally i was asked some
some point in time what i've had to
forgive myself for and it's for growing
because it means that my life does
change and that includes people
relationships work
where i live a lot of things change
but i choose me and i choose that growth
so what what do you what do you think
that is because then there are other
people where you know maybe they could
be titled as maybe asleep in some way i
don't know maybe some i think that's
kind of like a maybe a generalization
that people use but someone who's okay
with
the status quo someone that's okay with
these um childhood belief systems
staying in place their whole life like
what makes someone different i think
that the more aligned you are with the
power structures of
extraction and colonialism and
everything else that we've done the if
you the closer you align your personal
values to those the easier life is
so um
there's an anesthetization that happens
to all of us right now
when we come near when we decide to make
our metrics for for success
very similar to those that are handed to
us and that leads to this
state of general anesthesia where we
can't feel anything therefore nothing
must be wrong
and
you can do that for quite a while before
the deep emptiness or sense of
disconnect within yourself starts to be
a
an extreme source of pain in your life
and
at that moment it will express itself in
many different ways
like like well you know as a medical
doctor i see the more the most extreme
versions of it i think that you know we
have an epidemic that began in the 1990s
autoimmune disease which is kind of the
most blatantly obvious version of
destroy self
uh you're building antibodies in your
immune system you destroy your own body
and we saw an explosion of that
condition starting the mid 1990s and
that is certainly linked to things that
we did in our environment
glyphosate which i'm sure we talked
about the last time is chemical in our
food and water systems and rain and
everything else glyphosate destroys the
the tight junction boundaries between
the outside world and your immune system
and so now that we're eating and
drinking
roundup all the time we are
getting into this condition of leak
where we lose track and the outside
world leaks in we don't have a boundary
immune system reacting to everything we
can't figure out what itself
so there's that biological reality
but we also called that chemical
glyphosate we popularized it as
something called roundup which is kind
of creepy in the sense that
he's going to normalize a population
you're going to
try to round up a group of people
and you're going to
try to corral them in a way of being
that is not real you should brand
yourself round up
and
i think that that
is
what happens in the world is we
subconsciously name things correctly i
just closed my clinic which was a really
emotional process for me because i've
had it i've my primary identity has been
as a doctor for
almost 30 years now and
whereas
medical professional in some way you
know and so is
been a
a final surrender for me
congratulations
thank you
um and the reason for it was because
by being called a doctor it
does something similar to
branding yourself roundup it says you
know what you all are sick
and i am here to fix you
and i realized i was part of
the problem for my patients
my patients couldn't actually completely
heal because they believed i had their
answer
i have to step out of that role to
engage with my fellow humans
in a bigger way so that they can heal
and i can be witness to their healing
as
a
witness rather than as a physician so
we're now moving to the immersive
retreat model where we will bring groups
of people together to be witness to one
another's healing rather than
asking them to come into a medical
environment to receive external
inputs to find their health
total paradigm shift from
would you even call it a medical
standpoint
what would you call it
i think we're finally tapping into
something that's deeper than biology and
um
we have an eight-week program that has
developed over the last you know six or
seven years that we call dirty intrinsic
health and
it's an eight-week program that helps
lay out these eight fundamental steps
towards finding
a lifestyle that sports the fundamental
biology of
human life
and it's very simple stuff and
but once presented in the system that
allows you to understand your own
capacity for biologic thrive state
it frees you up of of the list of
diagnoses and diseases that you had
previously been defining yourself
as but this next step is going to be
much
more
powerful because
as important it is to clean up the
biologic environment for
a successful path towards fundamental
transformation the biology only counts
for 0.001 percent of you and so as a
doctor trying to do something to your
body to make you healthier i'm pushing
on a lever that accounts for 0.001
percent of you the
99.99
of danica patrick is actually a
vibrational
tone
that occurs in vacuum space
that is perfectly sung by your soul
and is resonating out of this light
being that animates a biologic
possibility of a human body
and so
when
people are drawn to you
is not actually for your physical form
your physical form is the direct result
of the tone that is sung below you
and the more that we continue to tell
people that it's their physical form
that people are attracted to then they
feel a burden
to that physical form because they're
afraid that that is their identity
and that's a terrifying thing because
that physical form changes over time
and so we think we are losing our
attractiveness as humans
by living life because as i live life i
develop a lot of evidence of life got
scars on my face wrinkles on my face
some spots
less muscle than i used to have
all kinds of evidence of change
and if i thought that humanity would
only benefit by my physical forms
presence then i would see myself failing
on a daily basis right now
but instead if i realize that i am
actually a resonance chamber that has
been defined by a light being to be
present to
change the way that humans interact with
their environment by me just being
present because i am a tone as well
and the tone that i have
if i make that the primary agent in my
life
there can be no sense of failure there
can be no sense of aging there can be no
sense because the tone is always there
and if i listen it is extremely coherent
and so
where we are stepping into is these
retreats
that are called journey into residence
and
i believe this is our next step is
humanity if we're going to change our
courses we are going to have to see past
the 0.001 percent shell
and we're gonna have to look into the
beauty of the the tone
that is coming from each
light being around us
and we have to be really quiet for a
little bit we're gonna have to listen
very carefully and
the listening
muscles are underutilized we have not
been doing that for a long time
and so if we listen to each other
we will learn to
do what i think is
the closest you can come to
a physical
demonstration of a miracle
is to sit next to the four vocalists you
know how to harmonize
oh
gives me goosebumps thinking about that
just
when you find those four people that
know how to bring their voices into
different tones
that when combined create something so
vastly bigger than any of the single
tones and so not so synergistic that it
cannot be added but as a logarithmic
growth of impact of the sound that now
is emerging
there's 7.9 billion tones on the planet
that we are expressing as human right
now the symphony that we could produce
if we were to listen to one another and
come into harmony with one another
would destroy infrastructure would
destroy
chemical matrices that have defined us
would destroy
fear itself would would dismantle
our
our belief of shame
the tone that each of us have is so
simple
and it is what provides us a sense of
self-identity
[Music]